hey up guys My Name Is AO happy New Year
welcome to 2024 hopefully the year of
very exciting stuff we are back at it
again with another code review
continuing on with the path Tracer that
was made by a 15-year-old this is a
quick little refresher of what we've
been looking at this is a path Tracer
made using C++ and opengl we've just
started scratching the surface so we're
going to continue on with this project
and to be honest I'm quite excited to
keep looking into it in fact it
motivated me to keep working on Hazel's
path Tracer during the holiday break
which I have been doing there might be
stuff to show for that soon so my hope
is looking at projects like these will
also motivate you guys to maybe try
something new or keep working on your
projects that you keep putting off what
I want to look at today uh with this is
and by the way one of the things I don't
like that I'm noticing already is the
mouse isn't locked when you move it
around which means that like if I want
to keep spinning like my mouse is on my
other monitor now and then eventually
it's going to stop I can't move right
anymore because the mouse is not locked
to the window so it should be locked to
the window and that's that's actually
really easy to do we might take a look
at that in a minute in fact let's just
do that right now so Escape closes the
the window which I'm also not a huge fan
of just because I am used to pressing
escape quite a bit to release the mouse
I know it's not locked in this case but
it's nice that if you do have an
application that you run windowed and
that isn't meant to be like a full
screen game if you want to capture the
mouse meaning that moving the mouse is
not going to move it outside of the
window then you need a way to release
the mouse otherwise you can't like
you'll have to alt tab basically or do
something like that in fact even alt
tabbing sometimes if you write your code
poorly might not even help with that
like the mouse can still be captured
into the window but you're in a
different application so it can be a
little bit annoying anyway point being
you need a way to release the mouse and
capture the mouse and so I'm used to
pressing escape this is just a personal
problem I'm used to pressing escape a
lot because in my mind if I'm in like a
first person camera like that was when
I'm done using it and I want to click on
stuff in the UI I almost always press
Escape in this case it just closes the
app I guess that's the other kind of
let's just say not very professional
thing about this if I'm like browsing
this and I want to like let's just say
say load a scene you can see as I move
my mouse to load a scene my whole
viewport is changing which is actually
super annoying I might add for a path
Tracer specifically why because I might
have the perfect shot like it might have
accumulated over like several seconds or
even like a minute and then I'm like oh
but I want to like I don't know press
the button to capture like a screenshot
of the scene and then as soon as I go to
press the button it has to start again
because that moves the camera so let's
fix that so what we're going to do is uh
and by the way I I have no idea what I'm
doing uh like this actually might be fun
I was going to look at something
entirely different today I was actually
going to look at rendering like I've got
render do open I was going to take you
guys through like all the rendering
stuff but this is just taking uh on a
life of its own so we'll see how this
goes so over here in the main file last
time we talked about why it's not a
great idea to put everything into the
main file I'll have the previous video
linked up there inside the main file is
where all the window stuff happens and
because all the window stuff happens
over here in the main file all of the
gfw stuff is already here so it makes it
a little bit easier for us we can kind
of treat this almost like we not
abstracting away like the all the window
system into like a different class and
into our own engine API or framework API
or whatever it might be we can just use
glfw directly as like an engine
programmer it's interesting uh because
and I'm planning to do like a little
engine programming series by the way
soon like specifically focusing on
different different systems and the
stuff that I mentioned last video but as
an engine programmer it's it's like I
have such an aversion to doing this
stuff like not because it's not it's not
bad like in this case obviously
obviously it's not bad at all but I
guess just because of my nature and
because of what I'm used to because of
my experience I know that like using
libraries directly like that without
abstracting it through your API can
sometimes be like that that's not my
go-to strategy for really anything and
the primary reason isn't just because oh
yeah I want my own API cuz that's cool
it's more so the fact that gfw might not
always be relevant and so if I'm putting
gfw stuff in this file it's a problem
now why won't it be relevant well for
example with hazel like we one of the
platforms that we really really really
want to Target is the Nintendo switch
that's not going to have gfw that's not
going to have any anything like that so
if you have inside your like main let's
just say gameplay code stuff that's like
oh yeah gfw like capture mouse or
whatever then like you're going to have
to rewrite that anyway because you can't
include gfw headers you can't link gfw
and also even if you could like well
that's not even going to do anything so
for that exact reason it's like whenever
I'm thinking about like oh yeah let's go
ahead and make like you know clicking
the mouse inside the viewport capture
the mouse the last thing that comes to
mind is me being like you know let's
write some gfw code right over here but
again in this case totally fine where
only using gfw I'm sure this is not
going to expand to a multiplatform game
engine or something similar so I think
the summary really is know your context
now speaking of learning programming and
being a better programmer there's an
excellent website out there filled with
lots of really high quality courses that
will teach you programming and that is
the sponsor of this video brilliant.org
now brilliant .org is an amazing website
filled with lots and lots of really high
quality courses on various stem topics
not just programming but their beginner
programming courses I think personally
are really good for beginners who might
have trouble wrapping their head around
what it means to write code how to write
code how do I make sense of this in my
head if you're looking at all of this
code and you're just not even sure how
it how the computer runs through all
this stuff how it works then brilliant
interactive engaging visual computer
science courses I think can really help
you out because you learn about all that
stuff like code flow and logic visually
and because math is really just like
well like this with programming it's
great that all of this like visual
interactive way of learning extends into
Brilliance math courses all the way down
to the very beginning with their
Everyday Math course and all the way up
to things like calculus you can play
around with Widget that control numbers
to see what effect they have visually on
the way that the math is working and
you'll also get quiz like every step of
the way to make sure that you're
actually learning and retaining this
information and did I mention that you
can just try it out for free for 30 days
with their 30-day free trial I mean
honestly that's kind of a no-brainer
just go to brilliant.org chero try it
out no downside see if you like it and
if you do brilliant have been nice
enough to offer the first 200
subscribers 20% off and annual
membership huge thank you to
brilliant.org as always for sponsoring
this video okay so we're basically yeah
I mean my plan here um this is
interesting how this has turned into
like a little almost tutorial but um cuz
I I swear I swear on my live there's no
what I intended at all but anyway hope
you you guys are cool with this we'll
get back to the graphic stuff next time
probably yeah let's let's have a look at
how we would do this so there's and the
thing is I don't know how to do this
this is the other magical thing about
this let's take a look at this I want to
see I know there's something about like
Mouse is it mouse curer or curer maybe
set curer I think it might be this
function over here and I think if we
look over here says the cursor to be I
don't know this is this is the actual
cursor so this isn't like the the the
Locking thing is it Mouse I swear it was
called like set curs mode or something
like that
mode set input mode is that it okay here
we go so yes so it is it's called gfw
set input mode sets an input option for
specified window but specifically you
can see that if the mode is cursor the
value must be one of the following
cursor modes right so this lets you set
a mode and a value so you can set an
integer such as curser to kind of pick
what part you're setting so instead of
making a whole bunch of different
functions they decided to make one and
use basically the parameter the integer
as like the what are you setting to what
value so in this case we would be
setting the cursor and it can be either
normal hidden or disabled so normal is
just the this is the state that it's in
at the moment permanently and then
disabled hides and grabs the cursor
providing virtual and unlimited cursor
movement that's useful for implementing
for example 3D camera controls perfect
right so that's exactly what we want so
the idea is very simple when we click on
the viewport and it focuses it then we
want to set it to disabled so that it
captures the mouse and then when I hit
Escape I want to set it back to normal
so that it's released we also need to
prevent escape from closing the
application you can of course if you
really like Escape closing the
application you can do a couple things
you can only close the application if
the curs mode is already normal maybe or
you can just I don't know have F1
release the cursor I don't know you do
you now I want to touch on how I found
this um because I think that was very
natural like cuz then I didn't know at
all where it was I love just natural
organic videos I literally had no idea
what the function was called I knew of
the function from previous experience
writing but again because the time of me
writing this stuff in a project like
hazel would have been like 5 years ago
of course I don't remember everything
that I've done in my life and whilst I
definitely could have Googled something
like gfw capture Mouse and I'm sure it
would lead me to this and maybe even an
example on stack Overflow the way that I
found it in this case was I use visual
sist which is a paid extension for
visual studio so Al shift s is the fine
symbol window which I really love I'm
not sure if Visual Studio has its own
version of something like this uh I
don't keep track of every new Visual
Studio release and and you know because
they're basically just slowly adding in
useful visual assist features cuz
they're so useful but anyway what's the
other competing product to visual I
think re sharper right the jet brins one
which I don't really like very much but
that one maybe has something similar so
anyway this isn't sponsored by vigil
assist or anything but I do like it for
this so Al shift s opens up this fine
symbol window this is really useful cuz
I can type in any symbol so functions
like defines even which I guess aren't
technically symbols but well actually
are they symbols I don't know they're
pre-process a directives I guess
variables like static variables and
stuff like that like Global stuff
whatever symbols appear in this like
entire solution um in fact you can limit
it to entire solution versus like
external dependencies and stuff like
that you can just be like yeah like I
want just all the glfw stuff and if
you're specifically looking for like
classes structs and names spaces you can
also limit it to that so you can see
this is just showing me those gfw
structs like the image struct so really
really really useful when you're finding
stuff and again this being visual assist
one of the things I like about visual
assist is it's just instant right like
it's just like that Search Everything
app that just just searches your
computer instantly once it indexes
everything this is very very similar and
so again if I am looking for that
function like you know GW set curer or
like set mode was it set input mode like
look how quick that is like instantly
that's searching everything so it is
really truly useful and it also you can
see the way that I've written this if I
zoom in here really analyze Cho's coding
here so you'll know that I'm adding
spaces between words and the reason why
is because the spaces are basically
acting as an and but they're still two
tokens so what that means is that if I
know that it contains the text the
string of text GF W in like those
characters in that exact order and it
also has mode in it but I don't know
what's maybe in the middle or I don't
know exactly the name of the function
then obviously if I just write JFW mode
it's going to match that exact string
but if I separate it out then I'm saying
that I want gfw and I want mode both of
those have to be present in that in that
symbol and you can see how useful that
is because there's gfw mode again and as
you can see it's matching input mode
video mode like all of these other
structs and like these are just integers
within structs as well because the the
kind of namespace I guess of that
variable is like contains mode in it so
anyway I really like this I honestly
think that all Searchers should behave
like this and I think some of Hazel do
but not all of them so this is a real
reminder for me to revisit that and then
once I find the function this is the
great thing about libraries like gfw
that have all of their documentation
inside the header files now it's just a
matter of me just reading just being a
normal human and being able to read
things and also being a little bit
patient and not being like give me the
answer now like let me just read some
text because here's the thing guys even
if the thing that you are currently
reading is not the exact answer you're
looking for I almost guarantee you will
learn something along the way so for
example like I might have only used this
function for things like you know
setting the mouse cursor but if like the
cursor was down here or whatever maybe I
would have read some other stuff during
that and I would have been like oh W J W
supports a raw Mouse motion like I
didn't know that for example so the
moral of the story if you if you take
nothing away from this video then what
I'm trying to tell you is learn to read
how are we going to set this up well we
already know exactly what we're doing uh
let's start by disabling the Escape key
so you can see that jelw key Escape at
the moment just breaks so it will break
from this while gelf W window should
close uh while loop here and thus will
obviously terminate this application so
instead what I want to do and just a Qui
little side note I really don't like on
line if statements I used to write them
back in my Java days I don't like them
because first of all I think honestly at
this point reading them is a little bit
harder cuz it's kind of like I don't
know on the other hand maybe if I was
zoomed out more it would help but anyway
when you read things like obviously
going down like a a decent column A
decently wide column is a lot easier to
read than going across huge lines
especially if we have something like a
27in monitor in front of us and so
because of that like I feel like you
know if this break was here here then
this is just great because I'm like if
break right like my eyes are focused in
this area and I know exactly what's
happening immediately in fact I don't
even have to read the whole condition
right because check this out Escape if
key Escape break that's all I need to
read in this sentence to kind of
understand what this is doing right I
don't need the key Escape last frame in
the window that's just details that I
don't care about everything I need is
here but the break being over here yeah
means like it genuinely took me long to
read this like I'm not joking but also
the other problem is break points right
so it's great if stuff is on multiple
lines because it's multiple lines right
so for example I can make sure that I
catch this condition happening easy
breakpoint on line 2 3 1 done if it's
here then obviously if I put a break
point here it's going to catch this
condition being checked which in this
case is every frame or like every time
you know if I'm not adding an object or
doing the sa file cuz I guess that opens
up like a different I'm goey window and
stuff like that okay anyway um so let's
do this so instead of breaking uh let's
get escape to release Mouse so we'll do
gfw Set uh input mode so Window mode is
gfw cursor and gfw cursor normal right
so in this case no matter what like it
will release the mouse you could get
input mode and if it's already released
I guess we can do that to keep the same
behavior but that's dangerous because
sometimes I like to spam escape to just
make sure the mouse is released and
obviously in that cases would close the
application so we might just ignore that
we'll just make escapee permanently not
close the application in this case so
now we're setting it to normal uh and
then we need a way to capture the mouse
now normally I would do that with like a
click this is a little bit more
complicated though because obviously I
can also click on the UI so if I'm
running this then if I like if I click
here I probably want to capture the
mouse but if I click here I'm still
clicking on the application but I'm
obviously I don't want to capture the
mouse cuz I'm interacting with the UI so
my point over here is uh it's not just
as simple as being like if left Mouse
button pressed capture cursor that would
be nice but that's not the case now as
far as I can tell it looks like the
actual image is being drawn directly
onto that final buffer I think and then
the I'm gooey stuff is being drawn on
top so my point is that the viewport
that we see is not an imuy window that
is then having an imuy image put onto it
like it does for example in Hazel this
looks like it's actually drawing
directly to the buffer and then we're
compositing I'm AMU on top probably by
doing this right which as you can see
we'll render so we're rendering the
scene first which happens over here I
drawing this like full screen quad and
then on top of that we're drawing the
window so what that means is that like
the way I'd probably do this is I would
check to see whether or not like we're
hovering over anything inside IM guy uh
that is like an actual IM guey control
and if it is then I'm not going to
capture the mouse if I click but if I'm
not then I will capture the mouse so I
don't remember how to do that exactly uh
I know roughly how to do it which is
very helpful but I don't know exactly
how to do this so we're once again going
to go on this journey and figure that
out together so there are a couple of
useful I'm goey things I know there's
like is well is any item hover it is
honestly probably uh kind of what we
want the thing that I'm afraid of though
is it might not include backgrounds of
windows so an item might be something
like a button or a slider or like a tab
or something like that versus like just
the background of a window but again
really easy to check because what we can
do and by the way rather than just like
printing this to the console because we
already have some UI up and running so
over here you can see we have two
strings we can search for scene
collection and FPS with a colon right so
if I just go control shift f for example
and I search for FPS colon then you can
see I I know now that is being drawn
inside my GUI CPP and if I double click
on that that's where I am I'm inside the
in collection thing so as an example if
I just do IM let's just do text any
item hovered and then I might just
Express this as like an INT or something
I can do I am goey is any
item hovered so that way we'll we'll see
like if it's still one or whatever okay
so as suspected you can see if I'm in
the background here any item hovered
actually says zero still which is false
but if I hover my mouse over this button
at object it's one so it only works for
items and not backgrounds and I don't
want the click to go through if it's in
the background because I'm clearly not
clicking on the ual viewport I'm
clicking on this right so the next
course of action is uh again my
knowledge unfortunately which you guys
might not have but I'll try and make
this a little bit more relatable maybe
if I didn't know what I was doing at all
maybe I would just look at this header
file just to see like if there's
anything useful so sure is item hovered
may not is any item hovered may not have
worked out for me but look at the stuff
around right maybe that's useful now get
item id what does that do so that g
gives me last item data that's probably
when I'm actually setting stuff though
so that's not what my mouse is actually
actively over uh what I do know though
uh is that g IM I think the I'm
context contains a whole bunch of stuff
and I don't know if all of them like all
these variables are exposed into
functions it's fine if they're not CU we
can still access the struck directly if
we so choose however I do know that
there's a bunch of stuff here so there's
hovered there's things like hovered ID
which is a specifically a widget which
I'm not sure if Hobbit ID
is yeah so you can so that's the Hobbit
ID now I wonder if there's like so
there's hovered item you can see there's
also hovered window inside here right so
I'm presuming if this is like null or
zero or something then we're not
hovering over anything now instead of us
trying to access this directly now that
we know that we can basically check okay
if a window is hovered or an item is
hovered don't perform our left click
capture mouse behavior uh but you can
see that this is is inside I'm go
internal right so we can get access to
this you have to include I'm go internal
that is something I guess I would avoid
if I can just because that's digging a
layer deeper into IM GUI and not using
their kind of surface level API but what
I can do is I can just copy this this
hover window thing and if I go back to
IM guy's CPP file so just IM go.cp this
stuff is obviously exposed if I just
search for hovered window and I guess
specifically maybe G hovered window to
narrow it down a little bit maybe I can
find a function that actually returns
that or alternatively I can search the
header file hovered window okay so
hovered window doesn't seem to exist
inside the the header file I'm not sure
why they didn't make CU they've got is
any item hovered it' be good if they
also had an is any window hovered but
from their use of hovered window you can
see that they're clearly sometimes
checking to see if hovered window does
not equal null so therefore are you
hovering over a window is what that kind
of logically makes sense to me in
English Okay so I just whilst going
through all this I just found a function
called is window H so I searched for
hover window inside the header file
right this was my search string uh
however it looks like hover window is
actually a function called is window
hover which is fine so there is a
function called is window hover uh and
there's some hover Flags which I don't
know what these are so let's take a
quick look at what they could be okay so
here they are so child right so you can
kind of reduce the list of like if
you're looking for like root Windows
child Windows like tool tip windows or
whatever okay cool so yeah and this is
for both item hovered and window hovered
okay great so since that does seem to
exist and and also by the way items are
inside windows I don't know if you can
have an item outside of any window so it
should be sufficient for us to just see
if we're hovering over a window so if I
go back to main here and actually before
we do that let's go back to my GUI CVP
and I want to change this to is window
Hobbit with flags being just Zero by
default and then you can see that yeah
if I'm over an item or if I'm over any
part of this UI oh hang on so this is
actually coming up as zero I wonder if
that's just because of where I'm doing
this in the frame I'm kind of doing this
in the middle of it's probably resetting
everything so I should probably do this
after I'm gooey or before I'm gooey
potentially before the frame starts so I
think that's good I just think that I
can't do it at this point in the code so
if we get rid of this and we go back to
main if we still wanted to test this out
around the time that we cared about it
which might be well my GUI update
happens here so let's just do it like
here for example and if I just do if I
am goey is window Hobb let's do like a
see out window I'll just do yes and
no and hopefully that will provide us
with some good data that we want to see
okay so we got some nose happening and
then oh we still got no we still got no
everywhere nice oh this is
contextual current window and if it's
hover and if they're equal probably
based on some filters as well oh man
yeah that's right this isn't is any
window hover oh there's no any window
hover is there why not that's so useful
oh there is or is there why is it
commented
out obsolete why is it obsolete what why
did they get rid of this
function oh there's oh cuz there's it
was doing any
window oh is that what we want is that a
thing kind of doesn't look like any
window is a filter oh there it is oh
there it is any window okay so we have
to use this with any window I think
right wouldn't have been bad I think to
have a function that just does that cuz
I feel like that's useful but you know
whatever okay so there's no and then we
got yes okay so if we're over this it's
yes if we're and that explains why the
other one didn't work I don't don't
necessarily think it was because we did
it in the wrong place I think it's just
because it was just seeing if the
current window was hovered over and
obviously that only applied to this
because we did that code C is window
hover within this Windows kind of
context okay so now that we have this um
we have a way to do everything so I
would do it in probably the same place
so we can add it behind this if S as
well since that's where Escape runs so
we can just probably move uh you know
this up here maybe I might do it first
inside this function and we'll just say
that if uh I guess we can do the the
mouse button so I don't know if there is
a function for that inside this API
there's check key but it doesn't really
matter I guess we can just use JFW so if
gfw get mouse button and then we'll do
window button will be gfw Mouse button
left uh so if that what are the states
again so returns uh yeah g press or
release so we'll just say if it's
press uh then we also obviously need to
check the I'm good
window thing which I may have gotten rid
of actually if you do control shift V
here's another little Pro tip control
shift V inside Visual Studio gives you a
history of all of the stuff that you've
copied like well the last 10 Things I
guess so you can see that I did copy
this part but then I overrode it like
because I control seed JW press but I've
still got it here so that's pretty
useful so now uh yeah I can just put
this in here and then I can do set input
mode copy this as well and rename it to
capture Mouse and then this will be GW
ker disabled I think right and that will
capture the mouse so yeah you can
rearrange these if statements if you
want but uh and also don't forget to
flip the condition because we want to
only capture the mouse if nothing is
hovered so if Mouse is not over our UI
capture yeah like I don't know is is
window hovered like generally seems like
potentially more code to check compared
to the mouse button being pressed so I
kind of only want to do that if we click
not to mention that clicking is
obviously not a frequent activity versus
us like checking this every single frame
I imagine it would be faster to check
Mouse button so that's my reasoning
behind why this goes outside and this
goes inside you can or also I guess I
probably would also just bring this down
like that uh the reason being that it's
nesting less so let's rearrange this cuz
you can see I get to tab that over and I
think that's good Okay cool so I think
we've now done this so let's try and run
this and see what happens okay so I'm
unlocked and everything so if I click
you can see the mouse is now locked
which is great cuz you can see I'm
spinning right and you can see I'm going
infinitely like I cannot stop like let
me rephrase I was going to say I cannot
stop spinning right I can stop spinning
right but I will not be stopped from
spinning right if I go too far and run
out of space on my screen because the
mouse is locked and if I hit Escape then
it's going to unlock the mouse and if I
click again it's going to lock it but I
can still click on this UI and it
actually locked it why you why are you
locking the mouse so it seems like
clicking on the background
look so clicking on an
item does capture the mouse but clicking
on the
background does not so that's a little
bit weird um cuz I guess that would mean
that I'd have to also be like I'm gooey
is any item hovered but that would be
weird because the item is inside the
window so little strange but there you
go so that's fixed that now that's
really weird again like I feel like in
most setups cuz I wouldn't have
necessarily in this day and age where
we're used to panels everything being
panels inside an application I probably
wouldn't have unless I was building a
game and had debug UI if I was building
like an actual application or something
like this I would have the viewport not
just be the background I'd have the
viewport be like a panel and if the
viewport is a panel then obviously in
terms of I'm guy it's really easy for me
to check to see if I'm hovering over
that panel and then that that's it like
this would be much easier because it
would just be is this window or like
panel am I hovering over it yes then
capture the mouse right if I click uh
whereas here it's it's like a method of
exclusion instead I have to be like am I
definitely not over any UI so you can
see I can capture it here and I can't
capture it over here which is good and I
can move this around now the one thing I
don't like is the camera moves even if
it's not captured so that's probably the
last thing I would change uh I would go
into here and figure out first of all
how the camera is being updated and just
not update it if uh yeah so there's
there's is mouse control situation and
then you can see it does check for
update and update so this I want to
prevent if it's not captured and the
simplest way to do this is obviously
just to check the input mode and if it's
not disabled don't do it uh otherwise
like again in in Hazel or in a in a
maybe a more complicated setup you would
probably just have like a buling inside
the application state for is mouse
captured and then that way you don't
have to like hit Jill OFW necessarily
every time not not that there like there
might not be a cost like a significant
cost with that at all but it's still I
guess it's B I guess it's just like a
general rule almost an unspoken rule
where you just think of where where you
just think that if it's your code if
you're hitting your own code you know
exactly what's happening whereas like if
I have to run gfw get input mode like I
don't know what that's doing behind the
scenes that might be more complicated
than it seems now obviously we can just
look at the code and see what it's doing
like that's easy but if we wrote the
code we don't even have to look at it
cuz we know what it's doing right so I
think that's why it's there's like a an
a certain level of not necessarily
unease but you you think twice when
you're like do I have to hit this third
party API for this or do I have a buling
that's residing in my code that just
will tell me yes or no but anyway so
let's just do and
glfw get input mode window gfw curser
and we'll just make sure that that is g
w curs a disabled which again I would
definitely drop this down I don't know
why there are there are if statements
with like multiple lines of code like
that all in one line seems a bit weird
but this I think would be what I would
basically do now if we wanted to check
out the cost um oh Jew isn't in here let
me just open up Hazel real quick just
because that's an easy way to get access
to some gelf W code so if I just search
for get input mode here it is then this
is what it's doing right so it's a
switch sa in for the mode uh and then
it's just jing a variable so it's really
not too bad like I wouldn't really I
guess I wouldn't be like let's optimize
this uh in which case I yeah I wouldn't
be too worried okay sweet so now we have
this um we can move these around
peacefully without the camera moving all
the time we can click on stuff again
peacefully the emphasis here is on peace
and then we can click and we can capture
the mouse we can move around we can hit
Escape we can go to uh load a scene for
example you can see that nothing's
moving which is nice it's pleasant we
want to move the camera we can click on
it we might need some adjustment cuz I
think if I click in different parts it
actually does move the camera and I
think the reason why it's doing that is
because it's recording like the last
position of the camera uh even if it's
not captured or well actually when you
move it here it'll save the last Mouse
position so I can calculate the Delta
then when I hit escape and click over
here it's calculating like the Delta
between these two positions which is
obviously huge and that's why it's
moving it so that's another thing you
could improve and I probably would but
otherwise I think it's it's nice
generally to have a scene that you can
basically adjust all these settings uh
and it'd be nice if they also re yeah
every time you adjust a setting it
should also restart like the rendering I
think the other problem maybe that I can
foresee is if you click on this and then
you drag the mouse out you can see it
captures it the mouse has actually been
clicked this Frame so it's like a repeat
count of zero rather than does the mouse
just happen to be pressed because that's
obviously different and the mouse can
remain pressed when you go over the
viewport and that screws everything up
so there's still a few tweaks to be made
but in general I think this is a nice
Improvement so next time what I really
would like to do is actually start
taking a look at the rendering code
specifically how these render passes
have been organized we'll probably open
up render do and we'll take a look at
how how I would dissect the rendering of
an application that I didn't write and
what my Approach would be to that this
is a rather simple application like
there's nothing really stopping you from
just reading the code I think in this
case but hopefully that will be a little
bit more helpful uh you know for larger
projects or really for any projects so
thank you guys for watching hope you
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
please let me know what you thought of
this style of video where instead of
just looking at the code I went in and
did some stuff like is that something
you want to see more of let me know in
the comment section below don't forget
check out b.org Theo and I will see you
guys next time goodbye